notre monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
j'ai une question est ce que vous savez
dessinée - pas trop je vais faire mon
meilleur dessin pour vous rendez bien
compte de la chose voici comment je
dessine quelqu'un voilà je n'ai jamais
réussi à faire mieux que sa tâche tant
que c'est pas mal
il ya une petite ressemblance
aujourd'hui on se trouve donc sur pocket
rocket institut en fait on doit dessiner
des pokémon en 45 secondes et buttes à
rôtir seconde fois qu'on l'a dessinée et
ben il se passe rien vous inquiétez pas
tout va absolument mal se passer c'est
parti la drôme mais [ __ ] comment
voulez-vous décès ça vaut bien ok ce
parti alors je pense qu'il faut
commencer par les bus ça c'est une
technique que mon grand père m'a appris
vite la poule 1 vite leurs impôts dont
je faisais mon envie de vite vite vite
vite vite cerné moussaoui c'est un
aimant puissant mais plus c'est
décidément [ __ ] mais non mais c'est
dégueulasse quoi parfaire ses labos deux
os et honteux qui est ce si quelqu'un
reconnaît manier ton je lui offre le
dessin en format jpeg voilà ce qu'a fait
très plaisir
magnéto magnéto magnéto mais comment les
gens pètent
voilà bien joué tu as gagné le droit de
voir l'image en plus grand je passe le
fera plaisir quand même à les nouveaux
pokémon krabi ans plus tard il est pour
moi ceci est une pince sans commentaire
la même taille que 48 bon moi j'ai fait
le cru que j'avais une heure et demie
pour faire ça comme ça la pâte les yeux
les yeux les yeux toujours fait résulte
qu'un tueur faire les yeux vite il ya
plein d'orange afin de rendre au là
c'est bon on a gravi c'est son portrait
caché à thème dans la bannière là les
gens qui ont des ces pokémon ils ont
carrément bien fait quoi voulez
reconnais tous sauf royal bien les gens
vous faire butin dans la guérilla comme
je préfère même pas le partager sur
twitter avec vous attendent en mai mais
quoi je sais que je sais comment faire
je sais quoi faire
chaque académie m on va lui faire un
mini corde assis sur un tabouret vite
bien ou bien on vient où m
y a pour nos équipes les gens le
reconnaissent plus t'as pas si chaud
kouda c'est tout tous les arbres plutôt
éloigné ce cousin d'une autre famille
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
le catch ou non ton chat non pikachu non
en fait tout le monde a trouvée à manier
ton j'ai dû carrément bien décidé
finalement ya du talent ou pas dans la
salle
1 pourquoi vous ne prenez pas pikachu
bon voilà attendez non mais si les sida
les genevois pikachu mais c'est qu'un
gros problème [ __ ] waterton ok mon
gars c'est parti tana taratata déjà ya
un gros problème au niveau de la tête
mais bon ça c'est pas grave avec des
pâtes mais non mais j'ai pas laissé de
place pour faire les carapaces [ __ ]
c'est comme s'il avait une tête est il
directement des jambes et des bras
accroché dessus ces barrages c'est par
abadie pas le cas les lignes de la
carapace voilà bientôt un viseur d'en
cloque dutil édition paint alors là là
je suis désolé mais là il ya un truc et
vous n'êtes pas me contre des salaires
mais [ __ ] handfield a les yeux qui
sort littéralement de la tête
il ya un truc regardez une mode la
carapace et un petit quand même au
niveau des mains non au niveau des
couleurs à ok ce parti souhaite faire un
gros bleu puis aaron blanc oh [ __ ]
j'ai fait n'importe quoi rien derrière
des de détail va se passer ici au voilà
le détail ça c'est une oeuvre d'art
aulas lors de la même plante de plants
versus zombies qui est décédé quoi sur
le champ de bataille
je n'y pense pas non non vraiment pas
moi je dirais petite harpe guitare oui
c'est ça le talent c'est ça c'est toi
non mais non mais c'est non mais je peux
pas lui j'ai déjà fait un chat taylor g
je refuse c'est la grève
[ __ ] je suis pas foutu de dessiner un
bon jeu comme de dessiner sans faire
exprès un mec qui sera fait de retrouver
en pleine tête voilà mewtwo ah oui alors
ça obligé mais moi au lam et moi sa tête
[ __ ] fait de mémoire c'est un peu un
peu dur c'est parti voilà à sept têtes
c'est alors qu'ils ont la main on va te
la péter une des trois boules comme je
l'appelle un peu dans le milieu c'est
mieux tous ces menus tout ça je vois mon
gars les yeux la bouche
voilà une tête de cheval sur un corps
d'algues j'ai concentré toutes mes
capacités pour faire celui-ci qui s
dites moi que j'ai du talent en dessin
qu'une carrière m'attend dites moi que
vous avez trouvé dracaufeu j'ai pas trop
comprendre you to you to qui sont ces
gens qui ont mimé l'heure de jeu sur
pokémon qui ont vu le parti de nous tous
encore encore et [ __ ] encore géré avec
une casquette oui mon gars aussi vaut
mieux arrêter les dessins la non tiens
je veux dire que j'ai pas tout pas
d'avenir dans une carrière des sénateurs
olala je suis content mais a remonté le
moral voilà c'est vrai quoi j'ai
l'impression que ce n'était pas trop
bien fait mais de façon c'est comme on
dit c'est le syndrome dessinateur il
pense toujours qu'il aimait dessiner
alors qu'en fait il a fait un super
dessin quoi bon mener au pokémon au mas
tard on en attendait là ya moins de fait
un triomphe tard green coupable d'une
aide qui dansa gabonais de bain ça a
failli tout ça paye tout ça peut être
tout alors là on s'est surpassés
alors là c'est incroyable ce qui vient
de se passer non mais regardez moi sur
réalisme à toute épreuve ce front fripé
bon je préfère ne pas le partager suis
là parce qu'il risque d'être un peu
choqué les gens quoi regarder il va je
n'ai plus en plus de temps à s'afficher
une [ __ ] c'est incroyable ça l'image
de save us carrément pas là et voilà
j'ai reproduit ce pokémon est facile je
suis là [ __ ] il est facile il ya des
feuilles à la place des pieds est facile
20 l'a vraiment bon pour le coup je suis
sincère là où le reconnaît quand même
bon en fait je voulais un truc qui gâche
tout c'est le bec
voilà moi ça va pas quoi là c'est pas un
mec de canard c'est un put de lapin quoi
alors là le talent bon coup je suis
peut-être un peu trop sur le mois le
pokémon
ok je sais pas ce nom tu as voulu
tricher psycho quoique enfin qui est
correctement dessinée toi tu es sorti
avec moi je crois pour faire des
compliments comme ça psycho couac est un
bois l'abc cocoa psycho quoique nous un
pouce à cochons pas trop un éléphant pas
trop et j'ai l'air vous avoir séduit sur
celui ci
mdr t'es pas sérieux bassila problème
c'est que je faisais vraiment séduit
donc j'ai intérêt à mettre la barre
clôture prochain bon bah vous savez quoi
moi je trouve qu'on progresse sur ce
coup alors toi mon gars touchez pas
traiter la terre soit je tiens tu es toi
tu as raté les normes plus âgées fait
des coucous qu'un dessinateur tiendra
mais quand vous voulez vous faire ce
truc
la spirométrie mais bon il n'aura pas
l'autre sukran on va être obligé de
l'aplatir la tête oh mon dieu c'est
dégueulasse or en dieu et sur les yeux
ça ressemble mais ça ressemble c'est
parti pour décevoir des dizaines de fans
22 précisément alors là le tas tâcherons
iep océan sonic attend la sonic je suis
désolé je veux finir sur un pokémon
incroyable ouais c'est beau ça c'est
beau ce qui se passe à l'écran tellement
beau jeu propose deux cours d'essai un
autre poteau relax je le connais son
meilleur ami ce tome on ira mieux au cm2
[ __ ] on flex proflex il faut il faut
réflexe mais armée y font pas toutes les
machines il a été nommé roffet surpris
toute l'image du kamikaze a fait et
voilà [ __ ] on dirait un rapport aux
baisses qui dort sérieusement oui
celui-là non mais là j'avoue par céder
et clermont encore du catch au fait
c'est quoi ce pied dégueulasse sûrs
d'eux et de pinces de crabe en est
génial avec 40 minutes d'expérience on
arrive à faire des choses formidables
là je pense que vraiment j'ai ma place
dans le milieu de la bd d'hergé gianni
des titres l'art abstrait pour les 6 8
ans il faudrait peut-être que tu penses
être prof de dessin pour les maternelles
aux stocks pour soi les jeux ne sont pas
compte que 2 derrière les crocs et la
brette rubalcaba brisé des raids comme
ça et ça t'amuse succion ça t'amuse bah
oui à moi j'ai 35 ans je suis plus aussi
des pokémon de toi tu me laisses moi
même comme ça jean-michel du mal se
suicida peu après superbe mois c'est
trop beau avant le tu pourrais gagner
des millions vous m'avez convaincu
c'est décidé je vais aux toilettes bon
et bien voilà jean s'est déjà plaint de
cette vidéo sur profit de roger soit il
en a poussé le cas n'hésitez pas mendoça
fera vraiment plaisir
aujourd'hui j'avais envie de faire un
truc un peu différent de d'habitude
j'espère que vous avez eu du plaisir à
regarder cette vidéo puisque bon en tout
cas j'ai pris aucun plaisir à massacrer
ses pauvres pokémon sur défense en tout
cas merci d'un de plus en plus nombreux
même si tous les jours ça fait vraiment
plaisir j'espère que ce genre de vidéos
un petit peu complètement bizarre qui
surgit d'habitude vous plaisent aussi
parce que moi si j'ai regardé par être
différent à chacun son trip dans une
nouvelle vidéo chat au monde
pis
[Musique]